[Music]
our next question is from jen on twitter
is it possible to own more things than
your husband and still be a minimalist
no i'm withholding becca's certificate
she has to get rid of 43 more things
and she'll officially be a minimalist
is true i do own more things than josh
although he definitely has more jackets
see that that's the examples you have i
don't know i don't count them and that
that's great yeah but it is it is easy
and the heart of this question is often
i see the other person's
faults or flaws and therefore
they aren't living up to my expectation
right and so i don't have an expectation
of bex
that she should own fewer things than me
yes i own the fewest amount of things
overall in our house our daughter ella
has the most things bex is
takes the silver medal i feel like i am
in third i don't i think ella has the
second place locked in
because i have all the kitchen [ __ ] and
sorry
can i swear now we're gonna have to talk
about that word
um yeah no you know i have all the
kitchen stuff
which yeah it doesn't belong to me but
i'm the one that primarily uses it i
have all the camping gear right like
i've got
two areas of
of
more items than
than either you or ella has we're
actually saving up money right now to
get a shed in our backyard in the
meantime we have a storage locker i say
we bex has a storage locker that i pay
for
and so we have a storage locker to keep
bex's camping gear in basically because
i don't want it randomly strewn
throughout the house somewhere we don't
have a garage we don't have an extra
space for it right now and so to get it
out of the way we have a temporary
storage unit
it's funny we were there the other day
to pick up a uh a surfboard thing or a
boogie board boogie board yeah yeah
ella's boogie board which we keep in
there as well and
i was there and this woman recognized me
she's like hey you're one of the
minimalist guys
she is the fake minimalist
and that really becomes the problem when
we become so legalistic about this that
it
you have a friend uh dave dave bruno who
wrote a book called the hundred thing
challenge this is way back in like 2010
2009 somewhere around there and it was
about living with a hundred things for a
year but it was not a prescription it
was about understanding that you can
live with less the number itself which
he acknowledges in the book is arbitrary
it was about understanding oh wow if the
average american household has 300 000
items in it
maybe i can live with a hundred and what
does that mean is that deprivation i
don't know and i think with each person
it's a little bit different with bex she
owns what she needs to own
and is constantly asking questions and
we're asking these questions together
and quite often
we can do this in a passive-aggressive
way that seems accusatory hey you really
want to keep this
as opposed to getting curious about it
hey bex you still using this
in a way that is genuine it's not hey i
think you should get rid of this but
we're holding each other accountable in
a way that is loving
not blaming or accusing the other person
for owning too much stuff yeah
just the other day um i so i'm
taking on a new hobby i'm gonna bake
with sourdough oh and i have wanted to
do i've wanted to have a sourdough
starter and to bake with sourdough for
over a decade i wanted to do it forever
i'm finally like making it happen and i
bought like this um
beautiful
ceramic
bread
maker thing that you put in the oven
and it arrived the other day
and i was like huh where's this gonna be
and i looked up on the shelf
and the way that we have things is
generally when one thing comes in
generally one thing goes out yeah and so
i found a
little bowl on the shelf and i was like
hey josh or are we using this are we
planning on using this do we do we still
want this around not in a passive
aggressive way in a loving kind
thoughtful way he's like
gives me a funny look for a couple
seconds he's like no we're good and the
reason i gave you the funny look is my
knee jerk reaction as a human being with
a hoarding tendency
is to say yes
yes of course we need that
now generally before we bring something
in the home we both agree that it's
going to come into the home
and occasionally we'll bypass that for
logistical reasons but by and large
to avoid the excess to avoid
the other person's expectations
right we'll ask questions where it's hey
is it okay if we get this thing or what
do you think about this oh you know i
think aesthetically this would be better
and here's why
right the other day she was talking
about getting a bird feeder uh for all
the hummingbirds that we have near our
house that the cats like to eat
the stray cats they'll jump up on the
bird feeders
uh our next door neighbor caught one
with it in his mouth on the bird feeder
just a hummingbird in his mouth uh we
have all these stray cats because our
lot where we were it was this it was
abandoned for a while and so like i
guess all the cats just used the yard as
a
as a dumping ground literally and you're
not gonna adopt all the cats uh well
wants to no i'm buying a slingshot
an aesthetically pleasing slingshot so
just gonna sit on the back porch and
like launch little pebbles
minimalist design anyway she shows me a
bird feeder at a neighbor's house and
she's like hey can we get something like
that for
the
hummingbirds i look at them like no
absolutely not and she's like what if we
get one that's more aesthetically
pleasing oh yeah yeah that's fine
and because they the neighbors several
three or four blocks down had a really
ugly bird feeder and aesthetics are not
the most important thing to me but they
are really important
it's the reason that flowers are
beautiful is
it's part of nature nature is really
beautiful right and so i don't want to
interrupt the beauty of our home with
something that is
aesthetically displeasing and so
what is this about what are we talking
about we're really talking about having
conversations via questions when you ask
me hey
are we going to keep using this bowl
what i am going through in my head
instead of saying yes i went to the 90
90 rule which is in the minimalist rule
book the minimalists.com rule book 1990
rule we also call it the seasonality
rule have i used that in the last 90
days
no
okay am i going to use the next 90 days
hmm
i'm thinking on this like let let me
don't have i'm not going to say yes
because it's easy to say yes to that
question oh yeah yeah i'll definitely
use it
that's dismissive let me not dismiss
this question let me be honest with
yourself with you bex let me also be
honest with myself because
if i'm being honest with myself no
probably not going to use the next 90
days let's let go of it together
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit
the
patreon.com
or click the link in the description
your support keeps our podcast and
youtube channel 100
advertisement free